the worst pieces of advice I've had are
always tied to things that are in and
around chasing money don't chase money
chase a gentleman my name is Claire see
I'm a partner at revolution and I'm 29
years old we invest in a really eclectic
set of companies or investors in things
that are pure tech plays and we're
investors and things that are sometimes
a little bit offline like sweet green
for example it's a salad company for us
at revolution we take a really
concentrated approach to investing and
we work pretty hands-on with our
companies we're really focused on people
because there are teams that we're gonna
be working with for a really long time
you know we're in these deals for five
to ten years and after that there's
still a big part of our family and our
referral network I think there are real
benefits to being a female in venture
capital
you bring a unique perspective to things
I have different life experiences than
my male counterparts on the fun taking a
different view on things and bringing
other perspectives is a really healthy
way to evaluate potential investments
the amount of capital out there and
venture capital has skyrocketed in the
past couple of years obviously
valuations have gone crazy and tech
entrepreneurship has blown up I think
kids are a lot more excited these days
about becoming an entrepreneur and a
glorified this vision of that then going
into traditional roles like being a
lawyer investment banker finding
something that sits at the crosshairs of
what you like in and what you're good at
is fundamentally what you should be
doing